homies 33% what is good LEF koe men here
I've been getting a lot of your messages
the last few days a lot of you are
asking what's going on where the
episodes where the full-length shows I
know you do all audio on Spotify and
iTunes and all that and stitcher but I
like to watch the show why isn't it on
YouTube I have some news some of you
might not like it at first we have to
trust me
I like it because it is for the good of
the show the full-length video episodes
are going to Facebook it is gonna be
only be our gridiron Facebook page
Facebook said hey Slavko guys kind of
cool we liked him we liked what he
stands for the 33% we don't only just
want all the new episodes but every
single episode he has done since last
Super Bowl we want them so what we're
doing here is we're uploading every
single old episode if you ever want to
go back we're gonna do that whole
process get them all on the ber gridiron
Facebook page and every new episode that
we put out will be on Facebook if you
don't have a Facebook we're it's also
gonna be will put the links on Instagram
so you can check it out there it's
Facebook watch we're gonna watch it the
reason I love it they're gonna be
helping us out with maybe even get more
people to help make this whole thing
possible so I'm very excited about that
so please join us over on the BR
gridiron Facebook page every new episode
full length will be going up there and
every older episode since last Super
Bowl when it became the left goes show
will be on there as well we're not
leaving we're not stopping we're not
finishing and when I say leaving I mean
like leaving bleacher report but we're
just going from YouTube to Facebook but
since I know a lot of you don't always
have social I wanted this to go on the
YouTube page so that you could see it
and know and I'll probably put the BR
gridiron Facebook link underneath it's
been a pleasure being on YouTube really
enjoyed it now we're moving on to
Facebook 33% please join me
appreciate y'all homies lef koe man out
see you soon